hey guys in this mkbhd video although
it's not a youtube tips video which is
coming actually very soon i've been
getting a lot of questions about using a
t2i for video and so today in this quick
video we'll be giving the pros and cons
of using such a camera as you can
probably tell by this footage dslrs are
really really good for taking video
clips outdoors you get a whole lot of
natural light no matter what lens you're
using i happen to be using the 18 to 55
kit lens you can get a lot of light into
the sensor and video quality looks
really really good
with these lenses i was manual focusing
and you will have to manually focus with
the dslr but overall there are a lot of
video rigs for things like this that
actually make the footage look really
good although i don't really use any
something you have to realize though is
that no matter how good your camera body
is it's not going to matter if you're
using a terrible lens so i highly advise
you even if you are shooting outdoors in
magnificent lighting to pick up a really
good lens and that's going to help your
footage turn out a lot nicer have better
accurate colors have it be sharper etc
now bringing it indoors to a tech
reviewer setting there are still a whole
bunch of changes to be made first of all
you have to get lighting and lighting
will be covered in another youtube tips
video that's upcoming but there's also
something you have to realize is that
manual focus is something you have to
get used to a lot of the camcorders out
there nowadays people use use autofocus
so you don't have to worry about that
but here you can see i'll bring things
in and out of the focus point of the
camera if you can spot it in the top of
the video and that's really what you
have to work with and if you get a good
lens with a shallow depth of field
you'll have much more of that
flexibility now in the short clip here
you can actually see one of those
effects is one of the most desirable and
yet one of the simplest most easy to
achieve effects with the dslr for video
and that's a shallow depth of field it
really lets the gadget be the star of
the show so if you plan on improving the
quality of your tech video reviews you
really do want to make the gadget the
star of the show even if you do show
your face or your hands in the video and
i highly suggest you uh work with that
effect if you do get a dslr for video it
looks really cool so that's basically it
for me and what my short experience has
been again keep in mind i am kind of a
noob at this so i'm still getting to
know a lot of this myself but if you do
plan on getting a dslr for video i
highly recommend the canon t2i and the
50 millimeter f 1.8 prime lens as a
beginner's kit either way this has been
mkbhd signing out peace
you